all right we are now live with the very
first we call it inaugural
uh dr stadler's ama session so i do a
lot of online events that are usually
focused on one particular thinker one
particular text people ask me lots of
questions
about that particular topic and then we
usually end up straying into many other
areas as a result as well
this one is an ama that means ask me
anything and i will try to as best i can
to answer the questions i i may not have
anything useful to say if it goes
outside of my field of competence
and i'm going to try to get to as many
of the questions as i can so i'm i don't
see any questions yet which is in a
certain way
a good thing so let me tell you why i'm
doing this in the first place as sort of
a prelude to answering questions
as many of you may know i'm i'm on
patreon i use patreon which is a form of
crowd funding to help
support the the work that i do you know
a lot of what i do is actually for free
and uh offered you know to the to the
world uh online
and so i use patreon as a way to try to
provide some income that then allows me
to um
uh you know do what it is that i do
so in a way it's sort of like uh having
people all get together and and
sponsor you or bankroll you or something
like that and so that is is what i've
been doing i i pledge to uh once i meet
certain levels of support on patreon to
do certain things you know people have
been after me for a long time to do a
podcast for example uh and that's at a
higher level or to convert my videos
into podcasts that that also comes at a
higher level but the very first thing
that i decided i would do
is an ama session
uh and ask me anything so it looks like
i've already got some questions and let
me start taking some of them
um
first question have you read the culture
of critique by kevin macdonald that does
not ring a bell uh and actually
uh i i've probably i've probably read a
lot of books that i don't remember
having read somebody asked me a question
in goodreads how many books i'd read in
my lifetime and i said i i have no idea
how many books i've read you know it's
sort of like asking uh some
over-the-road trucker just how many
miles have you driven
who knows you know probably put in
another 900 today
uh daniel jackson uh how many books have
you published can you tell a bit about
them and the best way to buy them
so uh to my chagrin i have at this point
in time published only one book uh
although i'm working on several book
projects it seems like i'm always
working on several book projects but
it's you know working on them and then
actually bringing them to publication as
a whole another ball game so the one
book that i have published is called the
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
philosophy debates in france and that
was back in 2011 and that's more of a
you could say a specialist volume
although i attempted to make
it as accessible as possible that's a
set of translations from this very
important debate that took place between
a number of french intellectuals about
the nature the possibility the the the
existence of of christian philosophy
um
and it's got about a hundred page
introduction a chronicle a chronological
bibliography that's about 25 pages so
it's designed to fill a niche in and
scholarship and um it's an area that i'm
i'm still pretty interested in but i
just haven't had much time to work on
lately i will tell you a few of the book
projects i'm working on right now
currently i'm writing a book on stoicism
and what in accordance with nature means
and that's supposed to be not an
academic volume although it'll be pretty
rigorous but for ordinary people
particularly those in the modern
stoicism movement who are wondering
what's all this business about in
accordance with nature and then the you
know addressing sort of the perennial
nietzsche quote that gets put up there
in the stoicism forums uh you owe you
stoics on nature and how nietzsche's
actually got got them wrong
on that and then i'm working on a few
books on anger as well which is another
subject area that that i do quite a bit
on
uh fusion writes what would you say the
benefits dangers philosophy has on
society so that's that's a huge broad
question
i would say that at this point in time
there aren't really a lot of dangers
that philosophy has for society
not philosophy as such
but there's a lot of benefits you know
getting people to actually think about
things in in a what we call a critical
manner which doesn't mean just making
arguments and you know bashing
everything but actually
looking to see whether the claims that
we're making have some sort of decent
foundation engaging with interlocutors
you know philosophy is supposed to be uh
the sort of the subject area for ethics
not every philosopher necessarily
including those in ethics necessarily
lives a a life that that
you know shows uh you know what ethics
is supposed to be about but i think
that's that's a a role i think that the
biggest issue though is that much of the
philosophy that you find out there is is
uh
very technical and
written in ways that make it
more or less irrelevant to most people's
lives so we philosophers have not done a
good job over the last 100 years or so
in making a case for the importance of
our our our work with some great
exceptions people who i particularly
like
um tyler says given that you're a great
communicator for the field of philosophy
would you say that philosophy above all
above other subjects has poor public
communication so there's a great
follow-up question yes i would say on
average
most uh people who are trained in
philosophy and continue in the field
wind up becoming academic philosophers
most academics are are not very good
communicators interestingly they they
also tend to be rather resistant to to
calls to be better communicators when it
would it really would improve their
teaching their their study
and you know some people are just not
particularly good or comfortable with
communication
and that's you know that that's what it
is but i think that if you know
when i hear my peers complaining about a
university for example there's another
university in in
missouri that just is closing in its
philosophy department and people get all
worked up about that
i ask okay so what outreach were you
doing did you actually make the case for
why you are indispensable did you show
people why what you're doing really
matters or did you sort of just rely on
the institution to cover you no matter
what um and i think we're moving into a
new era and i'll talk maybe a bit more
about that if we see some other
questions coming up
kyle asks a question that i don't really
have an awful lot of opinion on i should
actually because i was a mathematics
major back when i was an undergraduate
but that was over 20 years ago do you
believe mathematics to be discovered
invented or or both
i guess i would probably say both uh
in part because i think that there are
you know mathematical
truths that are out there but i think
that the the work that that human beings
do in trying to you know figure out how
we can we can make sense out of the
these these truths and map them onto
things
some of that i would say is is
invented you know if you think about for
example
um you know
cantor's uh discussion of infinity and
you know developing trans-finite numbers
or
gerdell's uh you know incompleteness
theorem which takes a lot of work to get
to understand
um by the way there's a really great
book if you want to try to get your head
around it gerda ascherbach
i think it's called an eternal golden
braid we we spent an entire semester on
that when i was a mathematics major
um okay here's a good question from dave
uh dave yen what does your philosophy
firm do exactly well a whole bunch of
things so there isn't an exactly thing i
would say uh the main things that i end
up spending much of my time on are you
know content production which you know
you've seen videos of me most likely um
that's something that that you know
we're we're doing um again some of it is
is supported by by uh patreon supporters
uh it doesn't really underwrite all the
work that i do but but a good portion of
it
um we offer online classes i i have a
lot more of those to build out but a lot
of what i do is tutorials with everybody
from you know college students to
lifelong learners to working
professionals to ceos of corporations to
other professors as well
i do a good bit of consulting work
primarily in ethics i'm working with two
firms right now one of which is an
australian internet security firm
another of which is not a firm but an
institution a psychotherapy center
um i do philosophical counseling which
is taking resources from
philosophical text thinkers and adapting
them to
you know helping people work through
their their life situations i do some
executive coaching some leadership
coaching as well
and i do some academic coaching um what
am i leaving out public speaking i also
uh
i created the the business originally so
i'd have some way to build my public
speaking as i was starting to do more of
that but then it kind of
branched out into a lot of things
um
so here's an interesting question from
ufe
lingdal
i'm sure i'm going to mangle this
sirensen what is your take on graham
harmon's object-oriented ontology
i have not read harmon
i've met him actually
over in switzerland at european graduate
school when i was a visiting scholar uh
one summer i was there with my wife
who's a
abd all but dissertation candidate with
that and i got to ask him an interesting
question
which drew a lot of laughs um i can't
say that i fully understand what what
he's up to so i'm not really competent
to say
much about that
um
so uh fario ghoul asks
uh can i explain exactly what
aristotle's universals and particulars
are um not really in this context that's
uh that's a long conversation
so i mean what i will say is as opposed
to plato for whom the universals are
these forms that are out there in some
intelligible world
uh for aristotle the universals are
there in the the particular things in in
so the in the substances you could say
and then we have kind of copies of them
or apprehensions of them in our our
minds that we
you know we don't really abstract it
that's not really aristotle's theory
you're not going to find the word
abstraction in there that's read in
later on but something like that
uh kyle irwin have you read middleton's
work on nietzsche's letters i have not
and as a matter of fact let me say from
the beginning that when it comes to most
of these philosophical figures that i
work on i do not spend very much time at
all with secondary literature in part
because i simply don't have the time the
people who i write on
um if you ever look at my cv you'll
notice that i've done a lot of writing
on uh aristotle thomas hobbes anselm uh
maurice blondel a little bit on hegel a
little bit on well some on jacques lacan
then i actually spent a good bit of time
like going over the secondary literature
but i just don't really have the time
for it most of the time
uh
anasamir asks what books do you
recommend reading on philosophy of
technology well so that's not really
an area that i'm all that well versed in
but i should be in part because what i'm
doing is totally mediated through
technology isn't it only as much of it
when i'm doing something face-to-face of
course uh it may not be
i you know i think that
for philosophy of technology um you know
heidegger
john dewey
very important people to look at sort of
you know foundational thinkers of course
you want to read bacon and and leibniz
has some interesting things to say
about about that that apply to
technology i think
you know when it comes to like cutting
edge stuff i don't really know who the
the key thinkers are and i'm not much
more of a more than like a dabbler in
that field but i really probably should
get my head around that the trick is
finding the time so i don't have a lot
of great examples
um
all right so i just
lost the thread for a sec when a lot of
questions pile up we it suddenly skips
okay so um
i'm only going to answer one of zero fo
iffy's two questions here because i want
to get to everybody's
what is your opinion on martin
heidegger's on being being the most
important metaphysical question
um i don't think there is a most
important metaphysical question
so i think that a lot of people doing
metaphysics will often center their work
around something that they think is the
most important metaphysical question and
i think it's perfectly fine because that
drives their their research project but
um i i myself
don't don't think that there's one
single thing that is the most you know
important one that puts them all into
context i look at it as sort of like a
constellation
of important ideas
um
well here's a really interesting
question from tara
alkadi
i'm very interested in philosophy and i
have a very rough idea but it's a
mishmash i wonder if you have any advice
so i learn in a disciplined way so this
is a really uh great question
and i think it's it's applicable to many
many people and i get variations on this
um from time to time
so
let me say from the beginning that
it's okay if it's a mishmash
and in two ways one is you know
philosophical works um very often
you're not going to get everything out
of them
the the first or even the fifth time
reading through them
and you know there's some where you read
it at a certain stage in your life and
then you read it much later and you're
like wow i there's so much more in this
than i i i realized when i was reading
it when i was 14 18 24
20 28 um and and that's that's okay
sometimes um you know things have to
work work on us for a while before they
they stick before we really get
something
out of it and um
you know it's always a question like
which particular philosophers do i
do i have to read um i want to you know
make sure that i'm not you know wasting
my time on people who aren't that
important or aren't going to be that
fruitful for me
and there there isn't there's all sorts
of guides out there about well you
should read this read this read this
nobody really has the the definitive
position on this because it is something
that we do have to work out
on our own um i don't think that
everybody has to read hegel but i am
devoting my you know i've devoted now
three and a half years to creating at
this point 207 videos on hegel's
phenomenology to help people read hegel
if they want to i don't think that
everybody has to read heidegger i don't
i don't i think that everybody probably
should read plato at some point
and descartes at some point and probably
you know aristotle and the stoics but
but i'm not going to say that you
absolutely cannot think philosophically
without encountering them
and so what we do is we we read some and
then it's sort of like this endless
accumulative process you know you read
some and you're like oh that was pretty
interesting i think i've got some of
these ideas
uh
and then you know of course some of them
vanish from your head as you're trying
to explain it to people but you go back
and you read it again and then you read
somebody else who's referencing them and
you're like wow they got something out
of that very different than what what i
did
uh maybe i'll go back and reread and see
if that's that's in there or if maybe
they're off base
um you know great example of this
if you read plato's dialogues
and then go and read kierkegaard who
wrote his dissertation on plato uh yeah
plato's conception of irony um
uh and then you go back and you're
re-reading plato's dialogues you're
probably gonna read them in a different
way
um similarly if you read nietzsche and
and you see what he makes with socrates
or you know read other people as well
so
i don't really have any helpful advice i
think but maybe that maybe that is
helpful
now here's an interesting question uh
totally shifting gears from tony
atkinson i have a kind of a populist
question but i think it's important how
do you tackle the question do good looks
matter or does beauty matter
so if you're asking how do i tackle it
in my own
personal life um it depends on what you
mean by matter
um obviously i think that it's important
that um you know i i look good and i'm
glad that my my wife looks good too
and uh you know um
it's about as far as i can go with it uh
if we're talking about whether looks
should matter like maybe in certain
fields or something i think there's
somewhere that's totally irrelevant like
looks really don't have anything to do
with whether you do philosophy well
although you know what we do find is
that student evaluations often tend to
correlate with you know the the
appearance of a person which is is uh
not a good thing
um there's probably some fields where
you do need to be good looking you know
fashion model right
but you know we have very different
ideas about what what constitutes good
looks i look at fashion models and i'm
like wow they are anorexically skinny
and
that does not do anything for for me
whatsoever i don't understand why
everyone thinks this is really great
stuff um and then when you talk with
other people you often hear them saying
the same thing um so i don't know really
what to make of that i mean we could
also talk in terms of like design too
does you know should we design things to
to
you know just do their job or should we
design them
to look good as well
um you might ask the same question about
food you know uh just presentation
matter i suppose it does you know
so i don't really have a great answer
unfortunately for you on that one
so oh here's an interesting one
and i realize i'm probably abusing the
word interesting at this point so i'll
try to stop doing that
it's from bourgeois that's a nice uh
little
play on words there
uh i found what you're doing is an
amazing thing you're helping many people
around the world which philosopher
caught your attention that made you pick
this path
there wasn't any philosopher that that
got me doing what i'm doing
unless i i suppose if i count my wife as
a philosopher because she's studying
philosophy and she is awfully smart
so i'm sure that a lot of people
watching this have already heard this
backstory so i'm going to go through it
kind of quickly
the work with youtube
posting videos and stuff like that
started originally because my my uh at
that time fiance got me one of these
little flip cams not this one in
particular was bulkier and it actually
said flip on it because back back at
that time there was a company called
flip which
went bankrupt eventually i think
so
um i began recording my lectures in this
critical thinking class and i couldn't
upload them to my own youtube channel
because there were limits on on you
could only you know load about 10
minutes or 15 minutes in so we put them
in the fayetteville state university uh
channel and that's where you'll still
find them because they they own those
those videos
um at the same time i was recording
shorter videos called dr sandler chalk
and tuck which is a way to kind of stick
it to the educational experts who are
saying chalk and talk is dead don't
lecture it's all got to be interactive
and i was like well i i don't know maybe
if you lecture well
that won't be the case
so
um the videos really caught on
and people were were saying oh you know
this is really helpful and they were
saying it's really helpful in large part
because usually their instructors were
unhelpful or they weren't able to go to
college and they were happy to be able
to watch these videos
then when i got when i moved up to new
york um there's a whole story there we
moved up to new york uh it was only
teaching part-time i was teaching at
marist college they they allowed me to
video record my my class lectures
and now we were actually doing real
philosophy you know like plato aristotle
cicero uh all the way on to to like
nietzsche and kierkegaard
and um those really caught on
and more and more people started making
requests and i started shifting
some of my time to
um creating videos that were no longer
in front of a class but but um you know
shot just like in here you know like in
front of a chalkboard
um that's part of our investment you
know that that tripod right there that
chalkboard right there the lighting
stuff that that you you kind of see here
all of that um is is we acquired it in
order to do this this kind of work
um there wasn't any particular
philosopher
that that got me into that but i will
say this to bring it to a close
i'm very privileged in that i get to do
the kind of work that i do
and i i actually i facetiously tell
people that i'm in sales
my product is philosophy
my customers are the people out there
and my value proposition is that
philosophy properly understood will make
a difference in their their lives
and
i've got a really really good product
so i don't have to do a lot of
salesmanship but but i do have to do
some translation work i do have to like
getting getting people into the showroom
you know so if i can get them in the
showroom and get them behind the wheel
of an aristotle text and help them with
the transition so they can figure out
you know they've never done a manual
transmission so they can actually shift
the gears right
and get them out to do a test drive then
they will continue on with aristotle get
many of them the rest of their life or
the stoics or descartes or whoever
so yeah a lot a lot of verbiage for that
one
uh
here's an interesting one gemini cricket
if the works of every philosopher had to
be destroyed all but one and you had to
choose who whose work would you choose
to be the foundation of the rebirth of
philosophy i don't really know but i
think that
you'd want to pick somebody
who
summarized other people's philosophical
positions so you'd get more than one
person in there so some of these great
assimilators like
like cicero or aristotle or thomas
aquinas
probably would be would be in there
uh
the triple perspectives asked what's the
best way to read summa teologie that's
thomas aquinas's
uh
main work
well
keep in mind that it is dialectical so
he's going to begin with positions for
a position against and then give you his
own position the other thing to keep in
mind i would say with thomas aquinas
this applies to other philosophers too
is it you know it's very structured
right and so you think that he's going
to talk about this particular topic at
this particular point and that'll be
like the whole uh the whole discussion
of it that's almost never the case in
thomas aquinas you know he'll talk about
for example you know uh the the will
early on in in the prima pars right but
you got to read a whole bunch of other
things to to get a fuller conception of
the will in in thomas aquinas philosophy
and it works that way so you got to do a
lot of you know drawing connections and
you got to read across the
the the work um
kyle irwin what is your take on popper's
view of plato in in
his open society i'm not a fan of popper
i think that his his discussions about
you know
verifiability are interesting and worth
looking at the open society is kind of
just a hit piece
i i you know
i think you could plausibly make the
case that that perhaps some of the later
thinkers that he's talking about could
in fact be tenuously connected with
totalitarianism
plato no i mean he he's you know popper
is not a good reader of philosophy
as a matter of fact
you know he's not worth
taking the time to take seriously given
that we don't have that much time but he
is very popular uh there's a lot of
people who read the open society and its
enemies
uh against unjust authority
do you think camus philosophy the absurd
hero is similar to an anarchist
philosophy yeah i think i'd say
um
camus problematizes any sort of order
that we have and i think if you want to
see
where it really plays itself out
you want to look
at um not you know the stranger which is
kind of you know early in in some
respects
uncharacteristic text
uh or the mythosyphysis and you want to
look at you know his later writings like
the rebel for example or letters to a
german friend
um
these are particularly good at sort of
problematizing any form of government
that's that's attempting to work for
justice um
there's uh some some long-standing
issues there for him
uh joseph tucker asks what are a few of
your favorite existentialist novels
well
that's an interesting question i i do
really like nausea
and
you know reading it in my 40s as opposed
to reading in my 20s i think i missed an
awful lot in my
my twenties
um
rilke's
notebooks of
malta lawrence briga very interesting
uh
piece um
of course camus you know um the plague
is pretty amazing stuff um but the fall
is pretty cool as well
um
you know so yeah that's probably enough
enough on that
um unfortunately i mean i do not have
any of you on all gazali because i don't
i don't read
uh enough of uh his stuff
john fisher choir what are your views on
animal rights argument and contemporary
analytic philosophy with peter singer
he's the only one of them i've read i
haven't read tom regan or john or jeff
mcmahon
so i can't really say anything about
about them um
and uh
peter singer interesting guy um i like i
like consistency and he is very
consistent across the board i mean if
you want a uh
you want somebody who you really know uh
where he's coming from that that's peter
singer um
i'm this is something that i've been
thinking about quite a bit but i haven't
been talking about much uh not not least
as we move in our household uh
originally for health reasons and then
for a lot of ethical reasons towards uh
a much more plant-based diet
um but i still have a lot more thinking
to do
about that that issue
um
let's go okay
oh here's an interesting
question democritus jr dr sadler in what
aspects do you consider christianity
improved on their neoplatonic
predecessors
well i mean it's important to keep in
mind that there's really three flavors
of neoplatonism
in its early development pagan
jewish and christian
augustine is a christian neoplatonist uh
pretty much you know all the people
you're going to read in the philocalia
are in some respect platonists um if not
neoplatonus at least sort of plutarchy
and middle platonus uh adding
christianity to the mix
um
many of the early christian philosophers
like justin martyr
um
clement of alexandria
um you know
they're they're looking at at um
platonism is sort of like the closest
thing
to christianity as a matter of fact
clemens really interesting because he
considers greek philosophy to be a
preparatio evangeli evangelii you know a
preparation for the gospel
uh in the same way that the jewish
scriptures we you know from the
christian perspective called the old
testament had been for the jews
greek philosophy was that for the greeks
according to clement
um i would say that that you know what
christianity added to the mix
um
was in part this you know sort of a
richer conception of of the human person
um sort of
other meditations upon the nature of sin
um you know some some sort of
you know coherent understanding of of
what the human relationship to the
divine involving in a prayer or
or other things would be and then you
know there's this this attempt to try to
bring all these things together in some
some sort of coherent perspective not
always uh successful the other
philosophy too that you know we should
think of is having exerted a very
important influence on
christian thought
would be of course stoicism
you know aristotelianism kind of fits in
there much more in the later
middle ages but but uh
platonism and stoicism you know if you
look at
read john cassian for example and look
at some of these conferences with the
monks and you'll see some stoic things
showing up without being called that
a lot of other
platonist things as well too
um
johannes g
haldorsson is there a deeper is odd
problem than just how things are isn't
necessarily how they should be
if so what's the logic for otts being
impossible
so
this is going to strike a lot of people
as being almost you know
paradoxical or heretical i when i hear
about the is odd thing i usually just
sort of just turn my ears off because
most of the stuff about it doesn't
really
apply hume hume didn't say that you
can't derive an ought from an is uh he
says that you can't derive an ought
solely from an is we've always got all
sorts of oughts in the background
as
sort of you know assumptions and
premises
and um you know so
that's you know that's
that's uh
as far as as much as i'm gonna say about
the is a lot distinction there but now
the deeper is uh problem than just how
things are isn't necessarily how they
should be so
um
i mean there is a disconnect between
at many many points how how things are
how we experience them and how they how
we think they ought to be
um
i mean in some respect that's that's not
really a problem you know the issue then
is to ask ourselves okay what's what's
causing this and we've got all sorts of
answers like well human beings are
dummies you know and screw things up uh
and that actually answers a lot of our
questions about that sort of thing why
are things so screwed up well because
this guy over here made this dumb
decision and this guy over here
responded to it in a dumb way and now
that doesn't answer everything but but
it does cover a lot of ground
i'm not quite sure what else i can say
about that
uh
sevkin what is the best general book to
get started in philosophy especially on
the greeks
i think it's good to start with the
primary sources
and you know i'm going to say something
here that i haven't said before but i
think could actually be
kind of a
good thing to to do
i usually say start with plato
right
but maybe it'd be better to start with
xenophon
and his discussions of socrates
then started then jumping right into
some of plato's early operatic dialogues
where socrates is really the central
figure
and then maybe compare the two of them
and then start from that that point of
view um but i think it's important i i
don't think that i mean there's lots of
secondary literature out there i'm not
going to say like i think this is much
better
there's so much out there that you can
sort of pick and choose and you know go
to the library and
run through it and see what would
actually make sense for you and what you
get something out of
um but
you know i think that you know at a
certain point i i think early on you
want to start working with primary techs
and i'm actually going to give you kind
of a pep talk here that i give my
students
who are these you know 18 19 20 year old
kids
when i teach college classes i tell them
look i know that you didn't read any of
this stuff k through 12 unless you went
through you know a really good school
and even then your your teachers might
not have been particularly good
uh so you know when i tell you that
we're going to be reading some plato
some aristotle some cicero some this and
that you're probably really worried
about that um
everybody that i have in my classes is
up to reading
at least some of these philosophers and
making some sense out of them um and
getting something out of it
so i think that's that's you know a good
thing to to keep in mind
um
yeah
it requires having some support but
there's plenty of resources out there
um deus ex anonymous would you consider
doing some videos on walter benjamin or
mock sterner
yeah i'd consider doing videos on just
about anybody but i have a huge backlog
of stuff that i'm working on and only 24
hours in each day
so this is where i actually you know i
created a video uh dr sadler responds
why don't you create videos about such
and such and in it i suggested that look
there's there's two things either
you got to wait until i decide to get to
that stuff or you can commission me to
to do that and every once in a while i
get people wanting to to do that
light in the night what do you think is
the future of philosophy um
well that's a good question so i think
that if we think about philosophy in
terms of academic philosophy
there's all these people are like oh
philosophy's dead you know uh
you know and there's always some some
silly argument about that and if you
have any historical knowledge you know
that people have been saying that for
over 100 years
so that's nonsense
but
academic philosophy as academic
philosophy is on life support in many
places
and deservedly so
because academic philosophers
in general have done a terrible job in
showing that they were relevant other
than you know sort of platitudes about
oh we're going to help you with critical
thinking and you know who cares i mean
you can in fact do that in history in
english in in business classes if you
teach them well generally that means
bringing in some experts who are often
philosophers but um it can be done right
um i'm not somebody who thinks that that
that academic philosophy really has to
be at the center of things unless it
makes its case and that requires
everybody in that department pulling
their weight
and
uh you know showing
you know day after day after day how
what they do really matters
i remember you know this is kind of
funny
i come from the trenches when it comes
to philosophy right i've never had a
cush position where i taught two classes
per semester and got paid better than
the people teaching four fours or any of
that sort of stuff so i have very very
little sympathy for those who are in
those positions and say that they don't
have enough time to do outreach
um i remember being on a fellowship at
notre dame a summer fellowship that i
you know had applied for and got into
with aleister mcintyre and we're sitting
there at breakfast because all of us
fellowship members ate together
um and i remember this one this one
person saying i'm having a lot of
trouble getting research done and
published and we're oh that's that's too
bad what's that about well i'm teaching
a five
and at that time i was routinely
teaching five classes a semester so a
five five right and so i commiserated
and i said
yeah you know um since i've been
teaching uh five classes per semester
i'm only publishing about one or two
articles a year
and she turned to me and she said oh i'm
teaching five classes a year
a three two
and i was like
and you're having trouble publishing
you're having trouble getting your work
done i i don't have any sort of sympathy
for that sort of thing at all
um so you know i think that academic
philosophers
what is the future of philosophy it's
not really with them
they're going to you know keep on doing
what they're doing they're going to be
well supported in elite institutions
they're going to have to really struggle
and and where they're really doing the
most work is going to be in the lower
level institutions
where the future of philosophy lies i
think is in this sort of thing that
we're doing right here
i think that it it exists in doing
philosophy and more public practical
and
professional but not academically
professional ways and i see that as sort
of reversion back to
earlier times and i'm comfortable with
it
so that's enough of my stump speech
there i think
um
jose and maria delgado
not a question there just a
nice comment i'm watching you from
venezuela i'm very grateful for your
reading of the phenomenology of spirit
of hagel thank you so much
yeah
very thank you for for saying that i'm
glad that you enjoy it i think i have a
little less than two years more to put
in on it if i stay on track
and then i've got to think about what
i'm going to do
next
um
sako arzuman what is your opinion about
tillich's god above god please elaborate
i don't remember i remember reading to
like a long long time ago i don't
remember that god above god reminds me
more of meister eckhart and the sort of
you know god god head above the god
i don't really have
a view on it other than to say that it
sounds sort of like gnosticism to me
that's always been my my impression
um
jed on the subject of mount mox stringer
have you read much or ernst younger if
so what did you think of his work i read
sterner a long time ago and i read some
younger a long time ago but it's been so
long that i can't really say
much
about it
you know
younger i read originally because i had
a very strong interest in fascist
studies which was spurred
from doing work on axiom francaise which
was a proto-fascist french monarchist
organization the reason i was doing work
on them is because the guy i was working
on maurice blondell was one of their
deadly enemies by the way somebody who
was a member of axiom frances who is
also an enemy of blondel
within the same catholic circles jacques
mariten
who didn't quit until
the accident frances was condemned so i
read some younger and interesting work
um i'd have to go back to it to really
have anything useful to say
uh harbinger x what's your thoughts on
marx that's a loaded question there
i read and i teach marx um i'm not a
marxist although i've actually worked uh
at one time for a marxist organization
because i'm kind of a an interesting
hired gun
in many respects you know i can get
along with people from all sorts of
ideological
backgrounds um
and work within their organizations i
think that marx is actually
right on on on some things i agree with
somebody like say mock shaler who says
you know marx is is is uh good but often
one-sided because there's such a
reduction of things
to the economic
um
and marx becomes sort of like you know
uh hegel and sort of like nietzsche
what we call a wax nose it gets bent to
use by so many people for so many
reasons i will say one thing too um
because there's there's marks like
actually reading marks and then talking
about that and then like you know
serious socialist and communist uh you
know parties and movements and all that
and then there's this like sort of fuzzy
you know uh
marxist stuff over here and then there's
like the criticisms of cultural marxism
i think that most of the people who talk
about cultural marxism
um are painting with such a broad rush
that they quite often don't know what
they're talking about
um
and i think you know that that's sort of
criticism of the right of the left i
think the same thing goes for a lot of
criticisms uh for coming from the left
of of the right as well so i think it's
important to be kind of careful with
that i'll tell you too when it comes
down to it my favorite work by marx
is the 18th premiere of louis napoleon
which is really
less about like economic theory or stuff
like that and more about how
infighting within a political system
leads eventually to
some candidate coming in who doesn't
represent any class just represents
power
and is able to you know grasp it and
take it
sort of prescient for
uh what what sometimes happens in in
political systems
um
let's see here
so pontinol
uh is a
has a good question
can i talk about gerdell's
incompleteness theorem and its
importance to epistemology and
philosophy at large
um
so this is an area where i think i've
seen a lot of people kind of misusing uh
or referencing you know gerdel's
incompleteness theorem
in a way that that doesn't um
really help out it's
it's um
strictly speaking it's saying that any
formal system
is either going to be
incomplete or it's going to be
inconsistent so what do we mean by a
formal system something that can be
modeled mathematically
so it really only applies to things
where we have an assumption that there
is mathematical modeling possible and
there's other ways of you know arranging
this as well
you could say it could be modeled
logically right but but you know that's
going to ultimately come down to some
sort of you know functions and things
like that
and it's very very complicated um proof
to show that
it's not it's not the case that like
everything goes out the window it's just
that you're not going to be able to have
a completely
uh either coherent or complete i realize
i've used the word complete there twice
the system
uh that covers everything so the upshot
of this was that the logistics project
was really a non-starter
and any idea that will reduce everything
down to algorithms or or something along
those lines is a non-starter too it
doesn't rule out the possibility of
artificial intelligence
uh it doesn't say that you know
mathematics is now all up for grabs or
anything like that right it's got a
somewhat limited
application
um
jazz car thank you for your lectures
it's a lot of learning from you i
understand each and every lecture of
yours i've learned so much from your
lectures that's that's very nice to say
uh ex nihilo is life worth living
um yeah i'd i'd say it is um you can
usually find at least something in it
that isn't completely crap even when
your life is really crappy and i've been
at you know some some situations in my
life where it's been pretty pretty
crappy um but there's usually you know
something worth worth uh sticking to
now that said i'm not going to be
preachy about it and tell everybody oh
you you know
whatever you're going through there's a
silver lining to your cloud or anything
like that because sometimes it is just
like crap heaped on crap heaped on crap
but i'm not i'm not one of the uh
ultimate pessimists you could say
uh e-tax any opinions on peter singer i
talked about him a little bit i think
singer's an interesting figure i like
like i said i really like consistency i
like when you know where somebody's
coming from um and he is definitely
somebody in the utilitarian tradition so
i i reference him in my classes
thoughts on jordan peterson jordan
peterson is an interesting fellow
i get a lot of people telling me that i
should have a dialogue with him or why
why am i not interviewing him or you
know i should
change what i'm doing and try to be a
jordan peterson clone
i get a lot of different
things along those those lines
what do i think of his approach to
repopularizing traditional values
i don't actually know enough about it to
say much because i don't get that much
time to spend like i said you know
on on looking at
other people's things um i i you know i
i hear a lot of people talking about
who's attacking postmodernism
um
i you know when i hear somebody saying
anything critical about postmodernism
it's sort of like hearing them talk
about cultural marxism it could mean a
million different things
so i'd have to take a look a closer look
and that means i'd have to carve out
time
in order to do that i know that uh
because of his his attacks on on certain
parts of the left he's become kind of uh
popular on the right but but i suspect
that um if if he really is you know a
great thinker he's not going to remain
popular with the right all that long
because a lot of that tends to be kind
of lower lowest common denominator
stuff
um you know
but that's the way it is with philosophy
aristotle pointed out this dynamic you
know a long time ago in any given
society you generally have two sides he
was talking about say the rich and the
many and they both think that they
they're completely in the right and the
others are completely in the wrong and
then you have the good
and they don't coincide with either of
those the arestoy the the the people who
who really deserve to rule but are least
likely to engage in all the
electioneering and cultural politics and
and all that sort of stuff and so
they're the ones who hold everything
together um
[Music]
i think that dynamic applies today as
well
all right so gubraj kong um when i read
schopenhauer i can understand his
teachings very clearly when i try my
hand on nietzsche i find it more
difficult to understand any ideas of why
well there are different kinds of
thinkers um
and they write differently
um
i think that there's a couple different
uh
things that that we can say
generally
we often find ourselves responding to
and getting certain figures more easily
than others
you know so for example
um
you know when i read jeremy bentham i
find him very boring but i can
understand what he's doing i find kant
challenging and i don't actually agree
with with content a lot of stuff but but
i can see the big picture and make sense
of it schopenhauer is very very fun to
read and i understand how he's he's
working things out as well
nietzsche is a very different stylist
and nietzsche also is much less
concerned with consistency than somebody
like schopenhauer is so i think it
requires a different work nietzsche also
coins a lot more words he's playing with
language pretty pretty heavily in his
his work um
you can see this especially when you
read it in the german in which it's
quite beautiful work except when he
tries his hand at writing poetry which
is not very good at all um
so i i wouldn't i wouldn't you know
take it to to too hard um you know it's
interesting i'll tell you from my
perspective
there are thinkers who um
i really enjoy and i think their ideas
are great but i find it very difficult
to write on them
and then there's others that i find it
very easy to write about like aristotle
you know
i have no trouble writing whatever
somebody wants me to write on aristotle
when i have to write something on plato
things get a bit dicer for me and i
don't really know why but but i do that
i know that it is the case
that's that happens so don't i wouldn't
worry about it too much just you know
keep plowing away at the nietzsche if
he's somebody that you want to read
some thinkers are always difficult hegel
great example you know i'm doing this
half hour hegel project i've been
reading hegel for over 20 years
i teach him uh and yet i go to the
phenomenology and i reread and i read it
in the german sometimes they even like
check the french french translation as
well to see what hip elite made of it
and sometimes i'm like i can't figure
out any of this stuff and it varies from
day to day some days it clicks better
other days it doesn't so don't don't let
it get you down
um
let's see
here we go
just had a big skip
here
um
[Music]
a lot of a lot of stuff here that i got
to scroll up through
uh
wow
i don't know that i'm going to get to
all of this
um
i think we might have to do sort of a
lightning round of uh of questions
um
okay here we here we're back
uh what do i think of arguments for the
existence of god i think that they're
very interesting i don't know that
people are often convinced by them
i can tell you that i myself have sort
of labored on and off with the
ontological argument so-called
because it's not really an ontological
argument the way that
textbooks make it out to be a saint
anselm for a long time
uh thoughts on slavojijak um he's he's
interesting
um
i wish that i had more time to spend on
reading his stuff because i find it very
uneven
um and frankly i i just you know i'd
rather
you know read read hegel or read marx or
read read kant
um
let's see here
do you why do you think hegel's
phenomenology of spirit is preferred to
a science of logic
because it became popular in the mid
20th century the logic was more popular
while the encyclopedia logic was really
the most popular
but but the science of logic was what a
lot of philosophers were thinking of in
terms of hegel
around the turn of the last century and
and the phenomenology became became the
book to read and so now we just kind of
follow along with that and hegel is so
tough and it's really hard to do more
than one
uh how did i learn ancient greek i i
took courses um
as opposed to most of the other
languages that i work with where i
effectively taught myself
i did in fact take a sequence of greek
classes at southern illinois university
and then i just kept kept on with the
reading
um
let's see
did i read any secondary material on the
phenomenology of spirit what is my
favorite um my favorite is hippolyte
and yeah i read a lot of secondary
material on the phenomenology of spirit
back when i was going to write my
dissertation on hegel i don't read an
awful lot these days again because i
don't have
a lot of time
and uh
yeah i mean i think a lot of people like
to read kojov you're really getting a
lot more kojev than you are hegel when
you read kojev but that's okay you know
because kojev is funny too
um
um do i think the aristotelian theory of
causes is useful for us uh can be um
i think that it can be useful as a
heuristic sometimes but i don't think
that it's i don't think it provides us
with an adequate metaphysical
understanding of things
um have i read the system of ethical
life by hagel yes i i've read that a
long time ago that's a good thing to to
read
um
what are my thoughts on undulus
uh interesting thinker i like some of
his essays quite a bit um i i don't
really buy into the sort of overall
project and i think that the lose became
very popular at a certain point and
sooner or later everybody had to talk
about the lose and i think that the lose
is such a difficult thinker at many
points that many of the people who talk
about the lose really don't don't
understand what what he's saying but he
but he lends himself to a lot of fun
you know interpretations and
applications to things
um so you know um i was i was you know
when i was doing early modern philosophy
i was really getting into his his works
on that which i i enjoyed
um
let's see what do i think of the claims
coming from the political right that
post-modernism is somehow responsible
for vicious moral relativism and
degradation i think it's nonsense i
think i think uh the idea that somehow
derrida or leotard or foucault
is responsible for that uh is just
terrible uh
political philosophy
you know um both right and left have
gutted
our our culture and our um our political
system uh and i think they both have
about equal share and in responsibility
in many different ways playing off of
each other
and then leaving you know the rest of us
uh holding the bag in the middle
so but you know it's typical and again
if we look back through history it
really helps to know about the history
of ideas
because you can see a lot of the same
movements a lot of the same criticisms
getting made over and over again just
slightly different terminology slightly
different ideas you know what the
political right is doing today
read about actual frances and you'll see
a lot of the same you know ideas
techniques being used against their
opponents
at that at that time
um
what is my favorite work by nietzsche
and why is it on the genealogy of
morality that's a great loaded question
right um
that is indeed my favorite work by
nietzsche although the birth of tragedy
comes pretty close
um why is it the genealogy i am a sucker
for taking a more systematic approach so
you know i really do enjoy like beyond
good and evil and you know human all too
human as well but i like the fact that
there's like a more coherent picture
being drawn in those two works
and i think that if you're going to
study nietzsche those two
are really important
thus spoke the arthur is really
important as well
[Music]
katarina asks what is your view on
plato's beautiful bodies the succession
of beautiful objects if i understand
correctly is in the symposium should
mean that someone with a beautiful soul
must have a beautiful face
well you'd think so but alcibiades uh
shows us that you can be pretty ugly
like socrates is and have a beautiful
soul
um
uh duty or deuts asks ann rand once said
the problems in america are
philosophical mainly criticizing a
manual account with the argument that
he's anti-reasoning what do you think
about that i think rand was quite bad
when it came to her assessments of other
philosophers um
and i'd say she's she's on the level of
sort of russell or popper when it comes
to
history of philosophy
and
i don't know the notion that that
somehow um
philosophical ideas are behind cultural
decline
you know
that's a big stretch um
all right let's see what else we got
here ah here's a question that's not
about philosophy
tough one
what is your favorite metal album
um
you know if you were to ask me when i
was a young man i would have said
automatically iron maiden peace of mind
and
now
i don't know i mean
maybe it would be
if i had to pick one
uh dio's holy diver
or
motorhead's um
overkill
so but that's that's a tough one for me
um
i'm gonna go a little bit longer it's
three o'clock now but i'll try to take
some of these that i can get to fairly
quickly
um
[Music]
oh here's a great one what do you take
the relation between philosophical
writing and rhetoric from dash
so you know aristotle in his work on
rhetoric says that all teaching involves
some degree of persuasion
and i think he's right there is always a
rhetoric involved in in all
philosophical writing the notion that we
can be like purely
uh you know without any sort of element
of focusing on the audience or you know
structure or
without engaging in persuasion i think
is nonsense it doesn't all boil down to
just just persuasion but i think it
plays an important role and if we want
to be effective as philosophers we need
to we need to study rhetoric
we don't we shouldn't leave that to the
rhetoricians
all right uh
here's a good one
is phenomenology dead has it been killed
off by speculative realism and object
oriented ontology definitely not
phenomenology is alive and well i
actually share my office with a
husserlian you know of all types i mean
you know that somebody's really serious
in in their phenomenology stuff when
they're doing whistle
because uh
uh you know
whis world's pretty dry uh but but he
thinks it it's great stuff no there's
phenomenology is gonna be around
you know for for the foreseeable future
this notion that we see in continental
philosophy so often there's also analogs
and analytic philosophy that like one
you know movement comes along now this
other movement is dead that's journalism
that's not philosophy
um and again looking back historical
perspective you're gonna see lots and
lots and lots of that
uh what do i think about sam harris and
and the likes um
[Music]
uh i don't really take harris that
seriously but then again i i don't
really you know
i've read bits of his stuff so i can't
really comment that much on it but i've
never been much impressed by by what
i've read or by people telling me about
harris
um this is kind of funny from jp 455 i
can tell that sadler's a big fan of
george soros no i've actually been a big
critic of soros for about
15 years
i've mentioned him as an example of
somebody who i think is corrupting the
body politic
usually when somebody brings up the koch
brothers i bring up sorrows um but it's
funny because a lot of the time you know
the enemy of my my or the friend of my
my enemy is is my enemy and there's this
whole logic that goes with it people i'm
in the middle
and i'm in the middle in part because
the left is nutty and the right is nutty
and they're nutty for different reasons
and they're usually off base on a lot of
things um and i don't even get along
with a lot of the centrists you know
but one thing that's a constant is
people on the left thinking i'm on the
right people on the right thinking a lot
and a lot of my friends are in that boat
too
um
okay
so muhammadu says great question what's
the difference between western
philosophy and eastern philosophy if
there are such different philosophies
well there isn't a western philosophy in
eastern philosophy the whole the whole
category of eastern philosophy is a sort
of western construction of stuff
uh the chinese tradition in philosophy
is just as rich
as what we call the western tradition so
it's the indian tradition
islamic philosophy and there was quite a
bit of it
we're always you know discovering more
and more interesting texts kind of fits
into the west kind of not great example
of this is just right down the street at
marquette university a friend and
colleague of mine richard taylor the
aquinas and the arabs project you know
he's got his students reading
uh avaros and even you know and all
these you know alfa robbie and all these
great thinkers and um you know
connecting it with scholasticism and
what was going on doing comparative work
taylor just gave an amazing talk about
abstraction and what's going on in
avaros work about you know happiness
um the notion that there's somehow
something called western philosophy
that's opposed to eastern philosophy i
think is kind of the sort of stuff we do
in textbooks but it doesn't hold up um
there have been confluences back and
forth you know think about the the
effects of of uh you know running into
uh indian thought think about arthur
schopenhauer right um or i think about
um you know the comparative work that
that went on we we talk about you know
comparative philosophy um you know if
you're going to talk about virtue ethics
in a serious way
you probably want to know something
about say the confucian tradition so
um
it's very difficult to wrap your head
around the totality of everything that
that's happening
in in all of uh all of that so
um
let's see
thoughts on derrida i i almost wrote my
dissertation on him at one point um
kind of funny
i'll tell you the story so i was gonna i
i was very into dairy though i went
through a dairy phase where i was you
know really really working with with his
his stuff and
getting totally into it and even like
getting into polemics with you know
derrida versus toulouse dario versus
foucault right
and um
i went to stephen tymon and i told him i
want to write a dissertation on darida
and he said let's talk about this
and he said i think that you want to
write your dissertation on somebody
who's really
important for the history of philosophy
somebody who's absolutely central
like say leibniz or or hegel or or
aristotle
don't write on somebody who's going to
be largely a footnote down the line
now that may sound very dismissive
but
you know i think when it comes down to
it 50 years from now
um
there's not going to be reading a lot of
people reading darida
and using his his thought for things
i think there will be people still you
know focusing on heidegger i think there
will still be people focusing on on
wittgenstein
um i think there will still be people
working on aleister mcintyre
i don't think there will be people
working on dairydown
i do think by the way there will be
people using foucault
i think that he his works have a greater
lasting power than dairy does do
um
let's see
uh ruby de silva what are your thoughts
on bertrand russell's history of
philosophy it's not worth taking
seriously um i mean if you want a good
history of philosophy from that time
reed cobblestone friedrich cobblestone
um russell
you know it's like with kojev right
kojev you get hegel through kojev
russell you get all these people through
russell
um
it's it's it's nice stylistically
because bertrand russell's a nice writer
but it you know it's it's sort of like
william durant's history you know uh
what what is his his book uh i forget
the name of it i mean you can learn some
things from it but you then you go and
read the philosophers and you're like
well he was totally off about this
um
so i i think it's not a particularly
good work
um
i'm going to skip over these long long
questions um
have i read any dostoevsky i've done
videos on dostoevsky
i am a big fan of dostoyevsky actually i
and and interestingly my favorite novel
by him is not the brothers karamazov
that almost every oh that's his
masterpiece
do you know what i think his masterpiece
is it's the one that's translated either
as the possessed or or the devils
um
that is a really really great piece i i
love that that one um
i suppose some people probably think
crime and punishment is the best one too
but i i like that one the best
um
scrolling down
pedro silva
uh do a series on neoplatonism reading
works from proclass yamblicus plutinous
zero dinosaurs the cappedocian fathers
well that would be a lot of work so
again that's where like uh commissioning
videos would would be the way to do it
i've got so much like right now on my my
desktop i've got all these cicero uh
video
frames that i i need to get to
uh and then i have other stuff from my
my classes and i got to shoot a whole
sequence on woolstonecraft as well and
and
more nietzsche more heidegger
got a lot of a lot of stuff to do
um
let's see
oh here's an interesting one vasily
meyer if god is dead is there any way to
avoid moral relativism
um and we're thinking if god is dead
we're talking about like you know what
nietzsche was calling the trans
valuation of values and the issue of
nihilism
um
you know the devaluation of the highest
value
um yeah i mean camus avoided it
right uh again reed
not just the mythosyphysis but the the
uh the rebel where that was an issue
could human nature biology offer an
objective morality still an is odd
problem there i've already weighed in on
the is odd problem
um i'm not so worried about that as many
people are but could could just looking
at human nature biology offering
objective morality it can certainly
offer something that presents itself as
an objective morality it's not going to
really take hold because it's not an
adequate way to understand the human
being
it's only one dimension of human
existence
um the meat and neurons that we've got
there's so much more
um and you know it's it's interesting
there's other great thinkers who take
this on you know jacques lacan is a
prime example himself uh because lacan
you know is one of these people growing
up in a catholic milieu rejecting it
entirely
uh and yet at the same time he thinks
that there's something really important
about about uh christianity and that
that what we would nowadays call in our
contemporary atheism is totally off base
and its views about things um i think
there's plenty of
models for people talking about
things after god is dead you know and
some of them are religious thinkers
look at gabriel marcel
you know um he's writing in a in in a
framework that doesn't assume that you
could just sort of like
bring god into the picture and fix
everything you know um
what is donald trump's philosophy
i don't know that there's anything so
you know so elevated his philosophy
going on in his his head or his practice
um
yeah trumpism okay yeah
but nobody knows what that is and it
seems to change from month to month
uh okay oh that's great trust me it's
the best nobody philosophy philosophy is
better than trump huge i think that's
that's that's that's perfectly on point
there yeah
um
okay let me see if i can get to the
end
uh
let's see a lot of back and forth uh
discussion
um
yeah do i think there's such a thing as
christian philosophy or christian
thought is there an inherent
contradiction between theology and
philosophy today well that's why we you
know wrote a book on the christian
philosophy debates
um i i certainly think there is
there's not just a christian philosophy
i think there's multiple christian
philosophies that are in you know
intrinsically christian and
intrinsically philosophical i'd say the
same thing for jewish um you know filo
alexandria back in ancient times jewish
neoplatonist really interesting guy
um
let's see what else we got here what is
my opinion on psychiatry um
uh well it depends on the psychiatrist i
was actually telling a funny story i
used to go to a psychiatrist
because i was taking an antidepressant
and i needed you know every so often to
see the guy uh for you know renewing the
dosage
and
i'd go in and he would get my my folder
and he'd open it up and he would he
would he never knew who i was
he had no clue and he asked me the same
questions every single time
and
then he'd find out that i was a
philosophy professor and he's oh that's
very interesting let's talk about that
and he'd ask me the same damn questions
about that too each time and after at
first i was kind of ticked off because i
was like
you know i'm well my insurance is
picking this up but look at this guy you
know he's he's
what what the hell is he doing you know
and then after a while i just kind of
brushed it off
now not all psychiatrists are like that
but but um i think psychiatry is is a
pretty hit and miss across the board uh
a lot of it has to do with with the
the person him or herself
um
let's see
uh
don't be a jordan peterson clone yeah i
don't think there's any worry about that
i don't think i could
um any thoughts on my khan yeah i've
written um amla khan if you go to my uh
academia.edu you're going to see some
some of my my writings on him i i like
him
um
could i summarize hagel's entire
philosophy in under a minute nope
not not possible
uh that would be kind of cool if i could
but i'm not the guy to do it
um
[Music]
okay so i think we are pretty much
he had to clothes a lot of the the stuff
is is chatter back and forth
with different people
um
well there is one one yeah so one good
point uh
people talking about cobblestone yeah
there's untranslated greek and latin
that's because cobblestone was writing
at a time when you could kind of assume
that people would uh go in there and
check it out
but you know um
[Music]
it would be kind of good to go in and
and do uh
um
learn what the what the stuff is here's
a here's a great last question this is
from la say justi andreasen would you
see yourself as a philosopher
or a historian of philosophy you seem to
always tell what other great thinkers
said about this and not yourself having
an opinion on the issue
so i reject the distinction
and i reject the distinction the way
that other great philosophers of history
have so i'm doing meta history of
philosophy right uh like andre goulier
i'm a big fan of his work i think that
when we do
uh what we're calling here history of
philosophy you know talking about other
people's systems
and their views and all that that we are
actually
um making it come alive and making it be
viable uh to engage other people and i
think that's that's very much needed
there's there's a sort of history of
philosophy that's just i'm just gonna
try to figure out you know what this
person's ideas were and i won't take any
stand on it and you know who they were
influenced by and that becomes very
academic but what i'm doing is much more
akin to philosophy as a way of life
which i see as as you know an integral
part of
philosophical work
i think that
originality and philosophy is highly
overrated i actually did a video on this
a while back
i think that much of
what you know we we call these days like
original philosophy or cutting edge
philosophy tends to be pretty you know
dull and
and and pointless stuff
and if it came down to either you know
explicating plato or descartes or having
my own opinions
i've put in enough time to realize
that
it's much more interesting and quite
frankly
these guys are often you know
smarter than i am
um and so i do you know the work of of
bringing bridging the gap making them
accessible for
for other people
um but i don't see doing history of
philosophy in that way as not doing
philosophy i see it as as keeping the
conversation going so that the people
who really did contribute
uh can can speak with contemporary
language
to to an audience
and i think that's more valuable than
most of what we call philosophy today i
really you know people who are just
philosophers right
and i do plenty of a pining of my own
you know in my off time um you know and
i do in some of my other videos you know
dr sadler's soapbox right i get up on my
soapbox and
spout my opinions about about things
i'm going to do more of those in the
future
but you know i
i've become more circumspect about that
because i've realized that i probably
ought to know what the hell i'm talking
about if i'm gonna open my mouth you
know and a lot of what i do with my
clients um
i would say is is much more you know on
the spot original
stuff um but that's because i think
philosophy pertains to the you know the
human condition we do it
in a lot of respects um you know in
specific situations dialogically
that doesn't get recorded unless i write
case histories down the line in which
case i'll change everybody's names of
course
but yeah so that which am i a
philosopher historian philosophy i mean
i describe myself as a history of
philosophy person but i only do that
because so many of the people out there
in philosophy think that you're either
analytic or continental and history of
philosophy is a nice tear team quid
right gets you out of their stupid
battles with each other
um
but
you know um
yeah i suppose that that's it for the
answer so about 20 minutes after um some
great questions um glad that you guys
all tuned in
and um
i see there's some questions i didn't
get to but that's you know
that's life right so i hope you have a
great weekend i really enjoyed this ama
session um we're going to do another one
when we get to a higher level of support
in patreon so if you're interested in
supporting um just go to my patreon page
and you know it's easy enough to find uh
you can just google it it's actually in
my linkedin my my youtube channel
um and so if you do that that that's
great i would like to thank my my
patreon supporters for helping me to
earn a living doing the kind of stuff
that i like
and helping other people
study philosophy worldwide so again have
a great weekend and maybe i'll see you
again definitely see some of you in some
of our other online events